Stars in the sky look pretty. Flickering,
intense diamonds dotting the velvety night.
But make no mistake: They are churning cauldrons
of violence, barely constrained thermonuclear
generators, creating enough energy to vaporize
the Earth a thousand times over.
Their lives depend on it. Heck, our lives
depend on it! But in their case, how they
live, and how long they live, depends on that
creation of energy.
And in this Universe, nothing lasts forever.
Very roughly speaking, we can divide stars
into two groups: low mass stars and high mass
stars. That line lies around eight times the
mass of the Sun, and the reason for that is
something we’ll get to shortly. Things get
VERY exciting at the high end, but for now,
let’s take a look at the low mass end of
the scale. Things are simpler there.
Stars make energy in their cores by fusing
hydrogen into helium. This is actually a pretty
complicated process with lots of steps, but
in the end four protons plus some other ingredients
get turned into one helium nucleus. Each
time this happens a little bit of energy is
released, but in the core of a star it happens
countless times every second. It adds up to
a LOT of energy: enough to power a star, in
fact.
The rate at which hydrogen fusion occurs depends
on how much pressure the star has in its core.
A higher mass star squeezes hydrogen harder,
so it fuses far more quickly. The rate is
so much higher, in fact, that even though
they’re a lot bigger than low mass stars,
high mass stars run out of hydrogen fuel in
their cores more quickly! The lower mass a
star is, the longer it lives.
In the lowest mass stars, cool red dwarfs,
the rate is so slow they last a long, long
time. But there’s more to it than that.
They fuse hydrogen only in their very centers,
and their cores aren’t very big. Outside
of this small region the gas is convective,
which means the hot stuff rises all the way to
the surface, cools, then falls back to the core.
That’s important, because it means the entire
star is available for fuel. Both hydrogen
and helium rise up through the star and then
fall back down. The star can’t fuse the
helium, but the hydrogen that makes it back
to the center is just more grist for the mill.
Even after a long, long time, these stars
can still shine as the hydrogen mixed throughout
the star eventually makes it down to the center.
So how long can a really low mass red dwarf
last? A trillion years. A trillion! The Universe
itself is less than 14 billion years old,
so even the oldest red dwarf stars are basically
infants. They’re just barely getting a start
in life, and they’ll look pretty much the
same for the next, oh 990 billion years or so.
Eventually, though, they do run out of fuel.
When one does, the star itself will be nearly
pure helium (plus whatever heavier elements
it was born with), and fusion will cease.
It’ll then cool, which will take many more
billions of years. Finally, it will be a cold,
black, dead star. And for them, that’ll
be pretty much that.
Or so we think; the Universe is far too young for
any of these red dwarfs to have run out of fuel yet.
That’s true for stars at the lower end of
the mass scale, up to roughly a third of the
mass of the Sun. But stars with more mass than that,
stars more like the Sun itself, work a little differently.
Their cores are bigger, and hotter, and denser.
The different conditions inside them means
the material in them doesn’t convect, the
hot stuff doesn’t rise away from the core.
What’s in the core stays in the core.
Outside the core there is a very deep and
active convection zone, but that doesn’t
interact with the material in the core itself.
This means that not only do stars near the
Sun’s mass use up their fuel more quickly
than red dwarfs, they have relatively less
fuel to work with as well. Depending on their
mass, their lives aren’t nearly as long.
For the Sun, that total lifespan is about
12 billion years, give or take. The Sun is
nearly five billion years old now, so it’s
approaching middle age. Its life is similar
to other stars of similar mass, so let’s
take a look into the far future. Will our
Sun go gently into that good night?
Ever since the Sun was born it’s been fusing
hydrogen into helium in its core. The helium
is trapped there, unable to be used as fuel,
and is building up in the core like ash in
a fireplace. As it does, the density in the
Sun’s core slowly increases. When you compress
a gas it heats up. That means, every day,
the Sun’s core gets a wee bit hotter.
That extra heat works its way out through
our star, heating up the outer layers, too.
A hotter gas shines more brightly, so the Sun
has been steadily increasing in brightness too.
It’s an incredibly slow but inexorable process; the Sun’s
increased in luminosity by about 40% since it was born.
And it’s not done. Helium is still building up in its
core and eventually it’ll run out of hydrogen to fuse.
Without fuel, fusion in the core will stop.
Helium can be fused into carbon (and a little
bit of oxygen and neon), but it has to be
incredibly hot to do so, and the Sun’s core
won’t be anywhere near those conditions.
Still, half the Sun’s mass is bearing down
on the core, so even though fusion stops,
the core will continue to contract and heat up.
It’ll get so hot that the temperature outside
the core will get to hydrogen fusion temperatures.
Like igniting a match by holding it near a
flame, the hydrogen outside the core will start
to fuse. That’ll occur in a shell surrounding the core,
adding its heat to the outer layers of the Sun as well.
When you heat a gas it expands. The Sun’s
outer layers will do just that, and our star
will grow to well over twice its current size.
Astronomers call a star like this a subgiant.
Not only will it grow, but its color will
change! The Sun will be giving off more total
energy than it does now, but its surface area
will increase so much that the amount of energy
radiated per square centimeter will go DOWN.
There’ll just be a lot more square centimeters.
This means ironically that the surface will
actually cool; the Sun’s temperature will
go down. Cooler stars are red, and so the
Sun will be too.
But the core still isn’t done. The details
are complicated, but the core continues to
contract and heat up. It gets so hot that
the outer layers swell even more, and the
Sun can bloat up to a fantastic 10 to 150
times its present size! It will then be a red giant.
Red giants are fantastically bright because
of all the energy percolating up from their
interiors, coupled with their enormous size.
When it turns into a red giant, the Sun will
increase its luminosity by an incredible 2000
times.
That huge increase in luminosity does more
than just make the Sun bright, though. As
a red giant, the Sun will be so swollen that
the gravity at its surface will drop substantially
from what it is now. The force of gravity
holding it down is weak, but the force from
all that light blasting out from below is
strong, easily overpowering gravity. Material
on the surface will get blown off like a leaf
in a hurricane. Think of it as a super solar wind.
That means the Sun will shed mass, a lot faster
than it does now. While it’s a red giant,
it’ll lose fully a third of its mass.
At some point, the core contracts and heats
up so much that the conditions will finally
be primed for helium fusion. Suddenly, helium
is converted into carbon, releasing a lot of energy.
In a weird twist, due to a lot of very complicated
physics, the core itself winds up expanding,
absorbing most of that energy.
In the end, less energy is pumped into the
outer layers, so the Sun’s outer layers contract.
The Sun shrinks. The outer layers get dense
again, which warms up a bit, and the Sun turns
from red to orange. It’s still pretty big,
more than 10 times its current day size, and
puts out 20-50 times as much energy as it
does now.
But then we see a sort of reboot of what’s
happened in the core before. This time, though,
helium is fusing in the core, and the carbon
is building up like ash. Once again, the core
starts to contract and heat up.
This dumps more energy into the outer layers,
they expand and cool, and the Sun turns into
a red giant AGAIN. This time it’s even brighter
and bigger, and loses even more mass, shedding
over half of what’s left.
In the meantime, helium fusion isn’t very
stable, to say the least. It swings wildly,
increasing and decreasing its rate by huge
amounts on very short timescales. The Sun
will probably undergo a series of tremendous
paroxysms, epic eruptions as the helium fusion
spikes, creating huge surges in energy production.
It’ll lose even more mass each time.
Finally, though, we approach the endgame.
The Sun doesn’t have enough mass to squeeze
carbon atoms enough to fuse them. They build up in
the core until there’s no more helium, and fusion stops.
On top of that… well, there’s nothing
on top of that. By this time the Sun will
have literally blown off all its outer layers.
It’s essentially a naked core: a hot, intensely
bright super-compact ball, not much bigger
than Earth.
We call this a white dwarf. Its fate is sealed:
It can’t generate energy, so it’ll cool
and fade over the next few tens of billions of years.
At that point, we can safely say the Sun is dead.
… BUT, that’s not always the case for
all stars. Some, with more mass than the Sun,
still go through another phase before dying.
They form what are called planetary nebulae,
and these are so amazing and beautiful that
they rate their own episode, which, along
with more fun stuff about white dwarfs, we’ll
get to next time.
So that’s it for the Sun. But what about
US?
Of course, the Earth won’t fare very well
during all this. It’ll get cooked before
the Sun even becomes a subgiant, and by the
time the Sun is a red giant we’ll be good
and fried. The average temperature on our
planet will be so high that it’ll melt rocks,
and in a sense it’ll look much like it once
did so many billions of years before, when
it first formed: a molten ball of rock.
But it gets worse.
When the Sun expands, it’ll reach a radius
very close to the size of the Earth’s orbit
now. Does that mean our planet itself will
be consumed by the Sun?
Maybe not. As the Sun expands, remember, it
loses mass. That means its gravitational pull
will weaken, and Earth will move out from
the Sun, into a bigger orbit. If things work
out right for us, the Earth will back off
faster than the Sun expands, and we’ll avoid
finding out what it’s like to be inside
a star.
Due to a quirk of physics, if the Sun loses
more than half its mass, its gravity will
decrease so much the planets will no longer
be gravitationally bound to it, and they’ll
be flung into interstellar space. I’m not
sure that’s any better for us.
Either way, the Earth will have been long
dead, and hopefully humanity will have figured
out the trick to interstellar travel by that
time. All those Earth-like exoplanets around
younger stars will look pretty nice in a billion
years or two.
Mind you, this isn’t happening any time
soon. The Sun won’t become a subgiant until
it’s nearly 11 billion years old, over 6
billion years from now. The first red giant
stage happens when it’s over 11.5 billion
years old, and the second stage a half billion
years later. This is a long, long time coming.
If the Sun had more mass it could avoid this
fate. A star with about 8 times the Sun’s
mass can: It has enough mass to squeeze those
carbon nuclei hard enough to fuse them together.
Those high mass stars have a much different
and far more explosive fate than lower mass
stars like the Sun…and trust me, we’ll
cover that in lots of fun detail soon.
And while this all sounds very bleak, not
all is lost. This is all part of the natural
cycle of the Universe, and in fact we wouldn’t be here
at all if it weren’t for the way stars live and die.
Be thankful for what you have -- and that we
can not only observe it, but understand it, too.
Today you learned that very low mass stars
live a long time, fusing all their hydrogen
into helium over a trillion years. More massive
stars like the Sun live shorter lives. They
fuse hydrogen into helium, and eventually
helium into carbon (and also some oxygen and
neon). When this happens they expand, get
brighter, and cool off, becoming red giants.
They lose most of their mass, exposing their cores,
and then cool off over many billions of years.
Crash Course Astronomy is produced in association
with PBS Digital Studios. Really, go over
to their YouTube channel, check it out -- lots
of cool videos there. This episode was written
by me, Phil Plait. The script was edited by
Blake de Pastino, and our consultant is Dr.
Michelle Thaller. It was directed by Nicholas
Jenkins, edited by Nicole Sweeney, the sound
designer is Michael Aranda, and the graphics
team is Thought Café.